mais de nouvelles manifestations se sont
déroulées à gaza aujourd'hui des
centaines de palestiniens se sont
rassemblés à l'appel du hamas pour
dénoncer l'accord de normalisation des
relations entre israël et les émirats
arabes unis signé la semaine dernière
les protestataires ont brûlé le drapeau
israélien et piétiné les affiches du
président américain et du premier
ministre israélien
notre message aujourd'hui est de dire
que nous nous tenons comme un bloc
imperméable face à toutes les tentatives
de nous précipiter vers la normalisation
nous condamnons héros jetons la
normalisation sous toutes ses formes
nous appelons tous les frères les
amoureux de la palestine et de jérusalem
à arrêter le processus de normalisation
et de s'en retirer et voire de fermer
les ambassades d'occupation est de
retirer leurs ambassadeurs
aujourd'hui nous sommes aux côtés de
notre peuple uni face aux défis dont le
principal est l'accord du siècle et
l'annexion des terres et nous sommes
également uni contre la normalisation
dans la région avec l'occupation le
fatah avec toutes les forces et faction
palestinienne rejette le projet
d'annexion l'accord du siècle et le
processus de normalisation par lequel
les états unis d'amérique et le
gouvernement d'occupation tentent de
pénétrer certains régimes arabes
personne ne peut faire la paix dans la
région à l'exception du peuple
palestinien il n'y a ni sécurité ni
stabilité dans la région
si ce n'est en trouvant une solution à
la cause palestinienne